was bisher ist ja alle schreiben einfach
dass der aussieht wie kapital wird ja im
laufe der woche zeigen ob es tatsächlich
capital raise wissenswerten
unkontrollierte surfen können und jetzt
viel spaß mit dem zweiten teil von
diesem seltsamen video ja okay machen
wir aber ich musste jetzt auch noch aus
beim wettkampf morgen gekündigt also das
gibt es morgen gefällt wenn man nicht
will sollte herzlich auf verlassen also
ok alles klar
alles klar gut ich weiß du sagst du bis
morgen dieses gerollte er auf krampf
dann wird man herz nicht brechen und 20
minuten zu spät
ich erwarte noch der kommissions
produziert gesagt dass sie seit einem
jahr in deutschland sind ne guck mal
[Musik]
körper in deutschland legal witz also
wahrscheinlich die tochter seit einem
jahr in deutschland sie sind halt heute
ankommen noch schneller fertig kuchen
gekauft ökohof zur selben zeit
lukas wie bei einer mika und ihrer
familie einen guten eindruck machen was
macht ihr richtig deutsch
ach das ist der vater von dem ich dachte
wenn irgend so ein kumpel von ihm noch
der couch oder freunden kommt ja dann
trink doch einen unheimlichen anderen
waffen kommen platz ist besitzen diese
offensiv einhalten du ist glauben nicht
mehr dass man kommt wahrscheinlich ja
darum könnten akzent kattegat wird muss
etwas aus meinem koffer holen dich da
vor einem jahr eingestellt hat ja einig
dass wir das bitte doch kommt
[Musik]
zeichnet dass wir ein bild ein paar ist
auch so dass fresse zu ziehen und auf
die man lieber mit oder sein was ich
will sind ich will doch zu dieser
iranischen familie gehen aber was soll
ich denn machen wenn meine freunde mich
nicht lassen
frau zu mir erwartet dass ich treffe ich
musste mal mitreden das hat ja wieder
nicht funktioniert ich wollte mich
entschuldigen ist sagt diesmal aber echt
nicht an mir ich konnte einfach nicht
magst dann hat mir fällt gerade erst mal
auf laut dem titel kommen die beiden
wahrscheinlich zusammen
nachgedacht wird sie ist und wieso 16
und 24
die bei höchstens 16 jährigen 12 oder so
ich weiß es doch aber dann kam meine
kollegen siri sprit mehr da ich bin so
was ich dann machen manchmal passieren
halt ganz viele blöde dinge in der
kurzen zeit ja viele dinge der kurzen
zeit passiert viel unbedingt wie also
gesagt die passiert es dass seine
freundin gekommen sie sozusagen das so
anstrengend weil es ist nicht klein und
zieht mich jetzt nach vorne
[Gelächter]
ich weiß ich habe ich die glauben kann
heblich es tut mir leid ehrlich ich hab
echt versucht ihre nachbarn mehrmals
vergessen wir das einfach
wie geht das ganze ein schnaps sie mir
eher die gefahr
sonst du eigentlich bei deinen eltern
sollten keine kommentare die direkt
deutschen fast gern mit meinem vater
eben jetzt noch einen platten
meine mutter ist schon vor jahren begann
politik erscheint die mutter liegt
wahrscheinlich in dänemark versteht ja
echt gut
er ist ihr vater ist mein vorteil ist
dass einfach der coolste haben wir
eigentlich ja wie viele menschen auf der
welt gibt und es gibt in diesen einfach
das ist schon wieder ein vielfältiges
todt verlegt das hat jetzt vielleicht
ist es die asylanten bekommt auch so
eine folge ohne wenn diesmal wirklich
also die ganzen früchte ist ja ok aber
das hat er wirklich so auch so eine
politische dimension
dass man eine folge über den nazis und
geflüchtet dann lacht und findet seitdem
ist auch sein gesicht war ja gerade war
sie mit dem geburtsdatum und es gab sie
machen mir halt angst ich würde auch
viel lieber mit anderen ruhigeren ort
mit dir zeit verbringt wendung nicht
jeden tag 50 auf dem friseur muss man
auch mal ein bisschen prioritäten setzen
ich möchte ich gerne mit nach oben
nehmen aber leider sieht von meinem
vater genauso weil meine freundin daher
ist auch eher schlecht gegenüber die
eingestellt aber die bald schon werde
ich mal knacken das geld mitnehmen und
morgen ist mein vater nicht da hast du
das vorbei zu kommen dann könnten wir
vielleicht mal ungestört zusammen sein
das macht zwar keinen sinn ja nicht gab
es zum ersten kampf verabschieden
bisher hat den interaktionen verstanden
dass seine haben sie vorher geschrieben
hat verleger zugegangen ist und dann
sozusagen jetzt erstmal hey lasst
einfach mal treffen
ja und dann machen
mich als echt voll erwischt aber ob das
so gut von amica sofort zu mehr aus sein
sondern wenn das simon mit krieg gibt es
richtig stress hatte meinen amica ist
das nicht die bohne sängerin ist es
nicht die lieblings mit dem jüdischen
nazi oder schwierig vor jagd nach der
ganzen scheiße passiert ist dachte ich
dass ich nie wieder was von der höhe
da bin ich echt froh weil ich meine dass
mit dem handy und was in meinen freunden
wird wie bei dem körper
da habe ich gedacht jetzt du bist anders
als die ich bin froh dass du so lange
[Musik]
hast du einen freund gehabt haben woher
kommst gesorgt
nun gibt es eigentlich autos passen
fließendes wasser das geht sich nichts
doch nicht alles wissen jetzt kommt
natürlich der straße landen hat darum
prozesse und dann stehst du deutsche
donald trump
ja ich würde echt interessieren was sie
kriegen die schauspieler die kriegen
wahrscheinlich not wahrscheinlich
irgendwo nach europa also jeder schafft
beträgt 100 euro für uns sofort ein
bisschen so einer folge die viral geht
und dann bist du einfach ein nazi
gewesen
in dieser folge derer ist es ja was geht
nicht in meinen kopf ohne wird sollte
wenn da draußen hilft mir darsteller ist
der das sieht oder jemand das sieht dann
hilf mir da schon erkennt geht ihnen
gescheit und schreibe mir auf instagram
ich will mal ein interview darüber
führen würde mich echt mega
interessieren
schumann songs mit ihren mitunter kann
aufschlagen aber der elefant das auch
nicht das was mir auffällt sondern szene
hat so eine idee so vater von es raus
und macht dann stresst und die das
dauert acht minuten acht minuten langen
schreiben sie hat uns eigentlich nicht
dabei
die sache sehr wertig gerade überhaupt
kassierte das team aus der perspektive
ein bisschen aus wie die altersgruppen
wir sind jetzt beide bei der etwas gegen
uns ich für mich
wir haben es doch gerade erst gefunden
das ist gerade alles so schön willst du
das alles wegschmeißen
es war wirklich mal 20 minuten du bist
auf der straße und sprechen mädchen
andreas kurz mit der ja dass man nun mal
austauschen
diese ok und dann bist du sowieso schon
so viel zusammen mit das hat keine
hoffnung natürlich hat so noch nicht weg
natürlich hoffnung kannst du auch die
redewendung das hat keiner ist
überstehen wird nicht so kann er trifft
er sich mit dieser wahrscheinlichkeit in
dem jungen dreck im orientalischen
scheißen den kopf verdrehen oder den
teilchen scheiben legale kraft sie ein
wirklich so bisher nicht danach ziehen
weil sonst nie zu reden sie gehen also
dass sie gefunden
guck mal was schon alles passiert ist
haben wir auch alles überstanden das
kriegen wir auch unsere beziehung ist
ausgeschlossen da gibt es echt kennen
und sowieso nicht ausgeschlossen
vertrauen ich sage dir was einfach
vertraut ihre beziehung war
ausgeschlossen
ja okay da ich finde das green der das
ende dieser wunderbaren ratgeber
serienfolge mit
also dort wir merken uns wenn euer vater
nazi ist und ihr eine geflüchtete dated
dann dann hilft durch diese folge auch
nicht weiter
doch natürlich forschern ist wie auch
heute das mal von mir und jack ruby